This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
in today's episode in honor of the new year and, you know, the ambitions a lot of us probably hold for 20, 26, we're going to be taking a look at success, specifically the very intricate, fascinating psychology behind success. Now, this is a topic that I've actually, I've shied away from this for a little while. I feel a little bit weird talking about it sometimes. I feel weird talking about success and ambition so outwardly and I often have this assumption that it's going to make me appear shallow or egotistical or arrogant. You know, if I were to acknowledge my own desire for success or acknowledge what it means to work for success, the psychology of it. But the fact is, what I've come to realize is being successful is a huge human desire and it's intertwined
with a lot of other major human desires. Our need to strive, our need to strive, our need for purpose and that doesn't mean everyone's version of success is going to look the same. Mine might be different to yours, but whatever it is, the psychology behind what pushes us to be ambitious and to want more for ourselves is so intriguing. And that is exactly what I want to break down today. What defines success? What maybe determines success in some people and not in others? And essentially, how can we use the psychology?
and we use the principles and the research to be super clear on our own version of success and the behaviors, the habits, the actions that might get us closer to that. So I'm excited for this episode. There is a lot of research packed into this short episode. Let's get into it. Firstly, I want to talk about what we actually mean by this concept of success, just breaking it down a little bit further because surprise, surprise, it is not as straightforward as we may assume. There are basically two versions of success. There's objective success and there is
subjective success. Objective success is the visible ledger, the part that I guess other people can verify without having to know you as a person. The salary figure, the job title, the degree, accolades, bestseller list magazine covers. It's something that we can see, count, compare, and often reward through admiration, respect, fame, those kinds of things. Think of objective markers as, I guess, social currency that signal value, but also signal something else. Talent, maybe hard work, passion, motivation. They essentially offer what we call a mental heuristic.
We assume someone who has success, someone who has things on the objective ledger that makes them successful must therefore contain another thing about themselves, a special secret trait that has gotten them there, whether that is true or not. So those markers definitely serve a visual purpose. They serve a purpose in general, but by themselves, you know, objective success doesn't necessarily mean fulfillment unless there is something more emotional and spiritual attached to, you know, what you have achieved and what you have done. I know people who have been on the Forbes 30 under 30 list, who have multi-million dollar businesses who have done incredible things. They have been on this podcast before and outly they appear very successful, but have
revealed, you know, privately to me, how miserable they are because they have objective success without also accounting for the second side of it, subjective success. So subjective success focuses on how you truly feel about and within your life, regardless of, I guess, appearances or accolades. So subjective success, if you want to experience it, has a couple of layers. The first is hedonic well-being. So basically the short-term evaluation of your state of mind or how happy we feel in the moment. you can have a lot of objective success but experience very little day-to-day pleasure because you are really
busy you are really burnt out you are lonely and you are unhappy so there has to be a level of hedonic well-being and then also eutomonic well-being this is the deepest sense that your life is aligned with your values aligned with your potential you are in an expansive state as a human being this element of success is not, it's not optional, right? To have a successful life, your life also has to have your goals, your achievements have to have personal significance. And yes, accolades may be a part of that, but crucially, they cannot be all of it. And now most of us have been trained to optimize the objective metrics of success and just kind of hope the subjective side kind of takes care of that. care of itself. Like we kind of just hope that it will fall into place and like we'll fall in love
with the thing that brings us money. We'll fall in love with the thing that brings us praise and admiration. But it really works that way. Study after study finds that objective metrics of success don't correlate to greater well-being. It's the subjective ones that do. So money, for example, may make you slightly happier, but only up to a point. You know, you may have heard about this famous study that $100,000 is like the threshold where any more money after that won't actually help your well-being. I think nowadays, isn't this crazy? Like the new figure is $250,000. The same goes with achievements and accolades. You know, I always think about these people who, like, famous people who have Grammys and Oscars and Egotts and whatever it is and how, is that
the thing that actually has made them a happy individual? Is that the thing that really matters? And I think a lot of them would say, probably not. The thing that mattered to them was relationships, was getting to fine-tune a craft, was creativity. And whatever that is for you, if that element is incomplete, you will be as well. So if you want to be successful, you have to have the combination of objective and subjective success. And you have to be able to care about the goal beyond the visuals or what it means for others. Now this is how we can understand this further. We can understand this further using something known as self-determination theory. This is one of the most famous psychological theories there is. I am sorry to my psychology students out there. I know you are sick of hearing about this, but it has to be talked about. It was first
proposed in the 1980s and the basic principle of SDT is basically that as humans, we function best we find success when three basic psychological needs are met. Autonomy, competence, and relatedness. When each of these is achieved, success is also achieved. And it's quite formulaic. It's not necessarily simple. So let's break down these components. The first is autonomy.
If you want to be successful, your goals have to be yours to begin with. They're not something that was put on to you. you, something that you feel pressured to do. There has to be a genuine, independent love for the thing. A simple way to test this is to take any major goal you have right now. Anything that you think will make you successful and finish this sentence for me. I chose this because. I choose to do this. I choose to pursue this because and then answer that question. If it ends with because it will look impressive because my parents expect it because I want to prove people wrong because I should. That is a sign that your motive is being driven from the outside. And I get, I get it.
I get that sometimes when you really truly want to get to a certain position in whatever area that is, there may be certain hurdles you have to jump through that don't immediately align with what you want success to feel like. You know, sometimes you do hard work because you do need to impress people to get to where you want to go or because you don't. need a certain amount of money to pursue a dream of yours. But at the end of the day, the outcome you envision way down the line, why does that specific outcome strike a nerve for you? If you want to be successful, you have to know why and you have to be clear on that. So the next part of the formula is competence. Competence is the feeling of getting better at something that matters
to you. It is the moment that you notice, oh my God, this thing that used to take me an hour, now only takes me 50 minutes or like, wow, like my third draft of this novel is really starting to say what I wanted to say or like I can run that distance I used to think was impossible. It's basically the intersection of challenge and skill. We call it the goalie lock zone. You need to be focused on a task or a goal that's not so easy that you might drift away or find it boring, but not so hard that you are paralyzed by fear and don't know what your next step might be. It's also what we might call the flow state, where you just feel aligned with your goal. You feel that it's not too difficult.
You're engaged in it. You're wanting to learn. You're wanting to push forward. You know, to achieve success, you need to also be pursuing competence. You need to be giving your brain a target, something to get better at. This is another defining feature of successful outliers in this world. they do not have vague ambitions. They give their brain something specific.
They give their mind, their soul, their body, something specific to work towards. You know, they don't just say, I want to be more creative, or I want to get rich, I want to get in shape. They have a specific vision that they can track their effort towards. And they then amend their efforts. They get better through the process. They also feel a personal sense of drive towards
that thing, that is being fueled by competence. Now, the final element to this equation, to this theory of what makes somebody successful, what makes somebody feel successful, is relatedness. This is the ability to experience a sense of belonging or connection with other people through the pursuit of your goal. It is the difference between numbers on a dashboard and work that feels really human. A recent Canadian study, looking at over 5,000 people, replicated a finding that has been spoken about for years. The happiest people, the most successful people, the people who say, I've had a successful life. The thing that they all have in common is good, long-term, meaningful relationships.
Even when we hold, you know, even when we control for money and for accolades. If you want to be successful, you cannot operate in isolation. You cannot skimp on relationships. look at your goals again, look at what you want one in your life and ask who actually benefits from this. If you can't name a single person other than yourself, your success is never going to feel, it's never going to have any depth to it. You're always going to feel lacking. It's this strange balance, right? Intrinsic motivation requires us to care deeply for ourselves first and to pursue something because we genuinely love it, but relatedness asks for that not to be the only thing
that you care about. That kind of point of balance that like knife's edge is where successful people live. At least that's what the theory says. I can think of a few people who aren't necessarily doing that. But that's what the theory says. They think not just about themselves, but how it's going to help or impact others. Okay, let's now turn towards the specific habits of successful people that fall into this formula. What a successful, smart people, the people we admire doing that we are not doing, and how can we take what they know and implement it in our own lives to find our own version of success?
That is what we're going to talk about next. Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe
that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. The habits of successful people that show up again and again in the research are honestly kind of boring. They're kind of simple. Dare I say that is why they work.
Now, a quick caveat here, I have to acknowledge that there are some theories out there that habits, these things we're going to talk about, may only account for like 20% of success. You could do all these things and maybe still not find what you're looking for. Another 20% is raw talent, but the final remainder of the equation of what makes somebody successful is just luck and its circumstances and its context. That is what one theory is on this. And there is a very famous book on this. It's called Outliers by Malcolm Gladwell that discusses this theory.
And his argument basically is that success isn't about how smart you are. It isn't about how hardworking you are. It's about where you come from, where you're born, who helps you and the systems that you're embedded in. You know, for example, Bill Gates, I don't know if you know this, but he had early access to computers. Purely because his high school was one of like three or four high school. in the United States with computers. So way before anybody else had access to these machines, he had thousands of hours of practice before anyone else started.
And he was also born in 1955. Like he reached adulthood just as like the personal computer revolution was beginning. Somebody who was born in 1980 like didn't have that advantage. Success is a whole lot of luck. But I don't find that discouraging because I, I truly believe all of us have a special talent for something. All of us have something we know just a little bit more about than others or have had early experiences with like Bill Gates that we can take and make into something amazing.
You need luck to be successful, yes, but you equally need habits. You need the full 100%. You know, if you leave out the behaviors and the actions, you won't reach a goal no matter how much is stacked in your favor. You know, think about Bill Gates. Yes, he had all these great things. A lot of people who have success have all these early advantages, but they could have also just done nothing with it. You have advantages that you don't know about yet until you act on them.
So as much as there is a theory that habits don't matter, they 100%. Do they are the thing that really pushes people over the line? With that in mind, here are the five standout ones that the psychology and the research says that successful people have. number one successful people fail a lot and failure is inbuilt into their creative and their into the creative process and their pursuit you know we often only see the perfect celebration photos the awards the medals you don't see failed assignments emails that never got a response dream deals that fell through this is the reality of every successful people every successful person
And I was going to say many, it's every. Realistically, the majority of the time spent working towards a goal or a dream is spent on countless iterations of the same idea, which never come out fully developed. Or countless attempts that just don't hit a target. Ask any person you admire, they all have a story of someone who said, someone who told them like, you know, it's pointless. what you're doing is pointless.
You're going to fail. That's a really bad idea. Literally every single person has that story. My favorite one is Meryl Streep. You know when she auditioned for King Kong, the director called her ugly in Italian, not knowing that she spoke Italian, and she didn't get the part.
Like, the literal Meryl Streep, Miranda Priestley, the icon, she was rejected. For all intents and purposes, like she failed. And so when you, fail. When you are rejected, that puts you in the same camp as her. That puts you one more failure closer to your dream. And the thing is, if she'd stopped at that first plateau or that first hurdle, she wouldn't be the success she is now. And she wouldn't have become what she is.
Having a resilience and a resistance to failure is a personality attribute that every successful person has in common and it's also a habit that you can you know strengthen in yourself secondly successful people know the value of working in silence such that outward forces don't interrupt their creative process or their their thought process i think we live in a little bit of like a share first act later culture but there is this curious thing psychologists noticed about that which is that when you tell people about your goals or about your dreams before you have acted on them, often that can mean that you essentially don't feel the need to go through with it anymore. I talked about this in your year for doing less and achieving more in that episode, but essentially telling people your goals
symbolizes the kind of person you are, which means that you don't have to act on those goals in the meantime. We get the recognition that we want. We get the sense that we are acting out the person we want to be by simply talking about what we want to do without actually doing it. Now, obviously, some people don't operate this way. Sometimes public acknowledgement can help you work harder when you feel like there is a standard you need to reach or a promise you need to fulfill. And sometimes people announce their goals as a way of accountability so they're more likely to follow through. The follow through though has to be crucial. You know, you have to be able to act on your goals and work on them without praise, without recognition, without visibility. I just think that the ability
to work silently makes you and your ambitions more intimate with each other, if that makes sense. Like, you have less fear around making mistakes because you're not doing them publicly. You have more room for experimentation early on, which is like, you know, the crucial part of any success story is, again, the failure at the beginning, the risk at the beginning. You get to grow without projecting embarrassment onto your efforts, without feeling embarrassed because people are watching, which can stop you from doing anything in the first place. So there will be time to share, take a slip out of the successful admirable people's books and just let your work mature first. Thirdly, successful individuals typically follow the 80-20 rule.
This is also known as the Pareto principle, which basically says that 80% of consequences come from 20% of causes or actions. Fancy way of saying a small part of what you do, a small part of how you act, creates most of the results. Now, if you're a perfectionist like myself, you may hate to hear this. We have this habit of like obsessing over 100% of every single detail. But in reality, a lot of successful people make sacrifices and they just satisfy requirements rather than perfecting them. They make things good enough on purpose. Not sloppy, not bad, but good enough. They understand the cost of obsessing over details that other people may not even appreciate.
The 20% is their focus. That is where they know they will see the most impact on the end result. And in practice, that looks like choosing and protecting the highest leverage pieces, before you start. If that's an essay, it is the main argument and structure, not the synonyms and the spacing. If it is studying for an exam, it is the high yield concepts and your retrieval practice, not re-highlighting every single paragraph. If it is, I don't know, a movie or a movie script, it is the relatable, intricate, cool character, not, again, not like the small, minute things that people are going to flip over, not how your script is structured or how it looks
visually on a page. Decide what must be true for your vision to work. What are the crucial three, four elements that need to be great and let that drive your effort. This also means deciding ahead of time what done will look like for you and what that will mean for you. and then respect that finished boundary. When will I be okay with, you know, putting this project or putting this desire out into the world? When will I let it be seen?
Is there a part of me that's just so afraid of judgment or embarrassment that no matter how much work I do on this, I will never allow it to be visible because I'm afraid. You have to find a way to also circumvent that deep fear as well. check in with yourself on whether this is good enough, whether the extra hour will actually change the outcome or just soothe your anxiety, whether the extra month will actually improve upon your goal or make you more successful or whether, again, it's just a form of self-protection. And I think this allows you not only to avoid burnout through additional labor and mental fatigue, but also, you know, be realistic about what's beneficial and what's
superfluous to your goals and prioritize your time in a way that it's going to be spent well and better. The cliche throughout this all, the cliche of this specific tip is basically working smarter, not harder. That is what successful people do. We are up to our fourth tip and this one is actually, this one's my favorite. This is the one that I rely on the most. It is my favorite habit of all. And that is that successful people learn how to enjoy hard work. Here is this like the sneaky superpower. Nobody probably taught you in school. You can actually condition your brain to find hard work and effort rewarding in its own right. Robert Eisenberger, he called this concept, learnt industriousness, it basically means that when your effort repeatedly leads to a meaningful reward,
the effort itself begins to feel good, maybe even fun and enjoyable. And that reward, crucially, doesn't need to be external. It doesn't need to be objective success. It doesn't need to be external praise or money or fame or whatever. It can just be enjoyment, satisfaction, progress or competence, like we spoke about. before. Basically, fall in love with what it feels like to get better and focus on the parts of the process that you really enjoy and that you find romantic. Learned industriousness is basically just for me romanticizing hard work until the work doesn't feel hard. When I was at university, for example, the way I got good at studying is that I really enjoyed and I romanticized late
nights at the library. It made me fall in love with the process and with the hard work because there was some like secondary satisfaction in it. So I rarely studied before midday. I really studied before 5 p.m. because I just found that that sensation of like, oh, it was almost like the narrative around like working hard and working hard at night and it's dark and like it's whimsical. Not whimsical. It's like it's romantic and it's like, I don't know, academic. Like that allowed me to experience learned industriousness. The work itself was something I fell in love with. It might be that you're really struggling to, you know, figure out a problem at work. And when you finally figure it out, there is this huge sense of relief so that next time, you know, you feel more
patient, you feel more willing to tackle the next difficult problem. It might feel like changing your environment so that, you know, going to a we work, going to like, you know, going to like, like a co-working space so you feel the romance and like the inspiration of being around other people who are working hard it may be setting up rewards for certain hurdles you know you have to cross certain things you know you have to do falling in love with reaching your limit and then that becoming your new base point and I know that sounds very cerebral and very like up in the air it's a feeling that you need to learn how to chase though because like wherever you are whatever you're doing, whatever your goal is, like there's going to become a point where it's just going to suck
and it's going to be hard and you're not going to see results and blah, blah, blah, like there is always going to be the dip where you're not seeing outcomes anymore. So when you cannot rely on the outcomes to reinforce your behavior, rely on the behavior to reinforce your behavior because you enjoy it just intrinsically. When you can hack that, when you can feel, that like I genuinely believe like you can achieve do be literally anything you want to be. Okay, we're going to take one more teeny tiny break and then when we return I have tip number five plus just like some very simple advice for you but important advice on how to include subjective success in your ambitions and in your dreams. So stay with us.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by her. a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed Correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. We have made it finally to tip number five. Number five, drumroll plays successful people structure their environments to make focusing easier. They understand the importance of environmental cues and environmental productivity. And let me ask you this question. How much laziness, procrastination, boredom, do you think comes down to simply the fact that your environment is stacked against you, that your phone is next to you all the time, that you're working somewhere with distractions. We romanticize willpower, but we also know that the context we're in, the environment we're in plays a huge role in our attention, our focus, our drive,
habits piggyback on our environmental cues. in behavioral science literature. This is referred to as choice architecture. It's basically the act of deliberately crafting an environment that makes the decisions you want to make easier and the decisions you don't want to make or the behaviors you don't want to do harder without actually forcing you to pursue a specific outcome. Basically, the most simplest example, if you want to, I don't know, I'm trying to think of a really basic one. If there is water by your bedside table and a soda in the fridge, you're going to drink the water first if you're really thirsty.
Like, it's just simple, right? It's just you've just queued it. If your phone is four inches from your hand, congratulations. You have created choice architecture. You have created an environment where you have built a phone checking habit because it is the path of least resistance. If your desk on the other hand is a single purpose zone, your apps are blocked. for 60 minutes you have a no phone space and a go phone space like that helps you break unhelpful habits by focusing on the environment and how you can manipulate it to help yourself keep it just super simple give spaces one job have a designated deep workspace have a designated workspace do not do homework
do not do work work do not do whatever it is on your phone in bed like that is your rest space or don't bring your phone in bed and only use it in your living room. Another big one, do not eat lunch at your desk. Trust me on this one. A 2021 study showed indications that it actually makes you less productive, even if you imagine, even if you believe it is saving you time. You know, if you're wanting to read more and stop scrolling before bed, pick an interesting book, put it on your pillow. If you want to learn the guitar, put the stand right next to your sofa or right next to the place where you're going to sit down and maybe even experience the most boredom throughout the day so that, you know, the alternative is right there. You don't have to go looking for it.
There is literally no friction between you and the decision or the path that you most want to take. When you make these small adjustments to your environment, you know, it turns your desired choices into habits simply by allowing or increasing repetition through the reduction of pain points between you and your desired behavior and therefore you and your desired goals. Okay, those are my five tips that I have gathered from the research, gathered from investigating this. Crucially, though, we have to return to this idea that a through line throughout all of this is that if you want success, you have to actually have an identity beyond success. And I know that sounds counterintuitive, but the danger of a narrow status-centered identity is that you create contingent self-worth. you only feel worthy when you're winning.
You only feel worthy when the singular goal that you have focused on is being achieved. And often I describe it as like having a toxic boyfriend or a toxic girlfriend. You know, when things are going good, it's absolutely amazing. When things are going bad, it's horrendous because you have nothing else to rely on. So take all these tips, do with them what you will, but make sure that you have an identity that is wide enough to contain all versions of yourself. be as focused as you need to be lock in full in love with the hard work also have a hobby have an interest because that will diversify your sense of self therefore making it stronger and this could
literally be anything volunteering coloring cooking for your friends you know there is this idea and and i think even sometimes like i've i've probably promoted it by accident but like there's this idea that if you want something you have to be so focused on it that you've that you've live, breathe, become the blood of that thing. But, you know, these other things are not distractions. They're actually necessary cushioning for the rest of your life, necessary so that you can stay whole and rounded rather than this like machine that is all about output and goals. I think the paradoxes and the important paradoxes is that pouring into your wider identity often improves the traditional markers of success as well. With less fear riding on each outcome, you take smarter
risks, you bounce back faster, you experiment more freely. And a last reminder, this is my last one, I promise, before I wrap up this episode is that just remember people find success at all ages. There is this huge, massive, major emphasis on finding success young and early so that you can ride the highs for longer so that you can prove yourself. I don't want any of us believing that you know, your 20s are the only decade where you can really do something or that you're running out of time because you haven't done it yet. You have so much time. You are not behind. Whatever age you are. And I literally mean whatever age you are, you could be 99. There is someone who has found their success older than you are now. And many, many others,
Other than that, have created their own version of success that is not glamorous, but was deeply meaningful for them at any age, any stage, any point in their life. So you are not behind. Timelines are literally, I will die on this hill. They are literally a social fiction. And real life will peak in all different places for different reasons. So if you are still sampling in your 20s and you're experimenting and you're unsure what objective or subjective success even looks like for you,
I actually think that's an incredible thing. That means you have even more to discover. You have a blank slate in front of you that a lot of individuals would be envious of. So as much as we have definitely highlighted and emphasized a lot of the sexy, glamorous examples of success. And as much as people love a young success story and they're in our face all the time, again, you have time. you can change at any minute if you are focusing on the 20% if you are leveraging talent leveraging context and then also doing the work so that when the opportunity arrives not if when it arrives like you are going to be so ready you're going to have everything you need in your toolkit to just be like
cool I'm going to hit the ground running I'm going to fail and I'm going to know that that is like failure is on my to do list I'm going to you know work in silence I'm going to follow the 80-20 rule. I'm going to I'm going to follow the learned industrious rule and I'm going to just like create the environments that I need to succeed. Like that is what you're going to be ready to do. So I'm excited for each and every one of you. That is all for me today. If you have made it this far, I want you to answer in the comments for me this question. What is your favorite success story? Who is a traditional, untraditionally successful person that you admire? and why is that?
I want to hear your thoughts in the comments below. As always, thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her wonderful, excellent contributions to this episode. She is a Star. Make sure that you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcasts. And if you have an episode suggestion, something we haven't covered yet, feel free to email us, The Psychology of Your 20s at gmail.com or send me a DM. I would absolutely love to hear from you. but until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself,
and as always, we will talk very, very soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.